[Musica]
allora forse voi non lo sapete ma io lo
so quando ero piccolo giocavo tanti ma
tantissimo c'è proprio forse era il mio
gioco di carte preferito anzi senza
forse cercava un sacco a yu gi oh punti
giocavano a magic i magic non l'ho mai
giocato purtroppo da una mancanza perché
so che è molto bello però giocavo a
pokémon due master non so se ve lo
ricordate la tanta roba
io ed è una vita e mezza che ne sono
gioco io ho visto che è uscito yu gi oh
due link che è un gioco che si può
giocare
giochiamo non so se mi ricordo come si
gioca sperli si avviano un tatto tmnews
sì sì confermo di non invocare satana
con le carte ci siamo o mio dio perché
mi ricordo niente ha già 4000 dai point
l'obiettivo ragazzi perché non ho mai
giocato a yukio ve lo spiego io erano
4.000 primo match point atto lo spiega
dove di riuscire a quanti all'avversaria
0 questo lo so dobbiamo semplicemente
come lo spiego questi cerca di un girone
difficilissimo giochiamo con le carte
ragazzi cosa io spiega dobbiamo buttarci
lai points e le funzioni punti vita
devono arrivare a zero e tipo ashton non
so come spiegarlo qualche io possa
evocare una carta di queste che ciò
quindi metterò il demone cornuto devono
è cornuto mai ho messo devono è cornuto
ora posso decidere di attaccare in
teoria no cambia face battaglia mi possa
attaccare il divo l'attacco ok economia
perché ci aveva meno di me di attacco e
restò di danni seri becca la zia
ok è così si gioca è passato talmente
tanto tempo penso almeno 10 15 anni
non mi ricordo niente ma niente prof
zero blocca difesa
magi e poi mettete quante ne vuoi giusto
e niente poi semplicemente
battaglia lo zio attacca la zia o lo
attacca direttamente anno dopo prima
attacca lì tutti i mostri che c'ha ok
stato sano ma ricordava via molto bene e
quello dopo dovrei vincere in teoria
mangiatore di uomini wow che carta
diversa da tutte le altre che hai appena
evocato dio mio non so proprio come
faremo a batterla blocca attacco il mio
meglio perchè avremmo già vinto quindi
sto facendo cose non so manco io sì sì
battaglia attacca lui abbiamo vinto dai
dai dai
ma è veramente è stata la battaglia più
difficile della mia vita
ricoverati a che la volevo portare a
cena ei non siamo uguali tv c'è i
capelli intendo valenti bene ed è tutto
regolarmente certo che proprio delle
carte fantastiche quindi niente cena c'è
una livello un po più alto che mi annoio
questo qua tipo questa mi sa che le
prendo perché a livello 20 quali prima
livello 1 lui a livello uno e cioè non
c'è il livello 1 livello 2 e 3 non al
livello 1 livello 20 va bene proviamo a
livello 20 siano state prendo le mazzate
dai proviamoci
il burattinaio che britto fratello mazza
con tokyo goodson più belli inizio io
incredibile allora facciamo che mettiamo
questo demone cornuto e mi piace che
vedo di speriamo che non evochi niente
di potente perché se non ce l'abbiamo
nel capra anzi vediamo un po temo nel
selvaggio vivace demonietto vivace di
moneta una secca cioè delle mani che se
ti graffia per caso sei morto ad
emettere lo zio che vediamo come
funziona secondo me quello in difesa cia
tipo di 2000 quindi ce l'abbiamo nel
carburante prescindere proviamo ad
attaccare
500 a ben o dai così che aveva l'effetto
quando questa carta viene mandata
distrutta nota cimitero pesca una carta
beh dai normale ragazzi non siamo messi
male in realtà pensavo peggio
pasqua livello 20 ce dove sei fortissimo
infatti appena mette una cassaforte di
channel capr anzi si deve
carta trappola se tu conta che se per
qualche strano motivo gli faccio fuori
queste in difesa ho vinto ma non penso
che gliel'ha fatta fuori e niente
tranquillo sicuro sono veramente così
bravo oppure veramente in realtà non era
livello 20 schifoso tipo termina turno
basta il tuorlo dopo vinto per forza
insomma passa dal va bene sì sì sì da
abbia vinto la livello 20 penso fosse
più forte niente non mi danno
soddisfazioni stagioni 6 pelato cosa
vuoi la mia vita seppur brutto questo
pure livello 20 wow
mi state veramente facendo cadere
addosso gli sci suisse tar ish tar najat
inizierà l'avversario figura sì però
alle 8 il sushi quindi devi muoverti
handan batte face by attacco a 1600
aveva li mortacci sua la bella e termina
questa mi sa che sarà più difficile
forse l'unica che mi dà un pelo di filo
da torcere speriamo che prendono cose di
attacco superiore a 1.500 vuole un
problema aiuto o nell'altro quanto ci
aveva sempre quella a troppo difesa non
esco sfondati la difesa che sfiga va
bene avete però non peschi niente di
quindi dobbiamo scartarsi le carte a
vicenda ragazzi ce l'abbiamo nel ca
pranzi pesantemente e fortissima come
sta bello era esattamente la carta di
cui avevo bisogno
grazie davvero raramente in difesa sta
roba
non mi ricordo se si annientano vicenda
se gli attacchi con lo stesso assisi
annienterà dicembre ragazzi mi sa che
sam per perdere però vabbè il
reclutatore custode di tombe qeusto dei
foo sorella tutti fortissimi che sta
roba
cioè siamo pari al bisogno di trovare
una maledettissima carta forte forte
una carta forte per cortesia grazie
sarebbe fantastico averla adesso in a
bottle pesano più attacco quindi ok
occhio lo zio attacca qua vivo e zheng e
sta facendo delle cose nel mio mazzo sta
facendo robbie keane non capisco ma va
bene i quattro di fiori zia questo è la
soluzione per chi prego spirito dei
libri vabbè non mi far male per forza e
due balle e combattutissima raga questa
veramente questa è la niente a vicenda
ragazzi sta diventa una pratica
incasinatissima si spera di vincere
venuta di agito agito agita o non vuoi
fortissimo porco demonio è veramente
forte quello li cercavano lo butto giù
mai
ragazzi questa partita è proprio
difficile demone cornuto un ottimo
niente mi sa che oggi perdiamo così
giusto presentimento il momento in cui
viene sconfitto e prendi tutto quello
che ti di prendere in faccia morte vieni
a me me lo merito
ragazzi ho perso contro una base almeno
n spero che vi sia piaciuto il video
meno male che ho perso perché sono state
andato avanti tutto il giorno mi sono
contento in realtà era giuliano links ci
ho provato e applicato era per
ricordarmi un attimo come si giocava
aiuto è stato bello tornare nel mood sia
piaciuta ragazzi con piacere di social
come iniziare semstre prestiti
chiedetevi e noi come sempre ci
rivediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]